hey everybody welcome back to nature
Park what you're looking at right now is
something which I don't usually feature
in my time lapses but what is one of the
most important things to me when making
parks it's laying out a very rough
sketch of what an area is going to look
like and trying out all the buildings
facades the path work and the rights to
kind of get an idea of what you want to
go for and now this definitely won't be
the final thing all of the buildings
which I'm placing right now will be
replaced by actual buildings later on
but it's really a rough in-game sketch
of what it's going to look like kind of
like in rollercoaster [ __ ] 3 what many
people would used to do is use the
ground textures to mark down where
buildings are going to be and where
paths are gonna go and then when you
start building things you kind of
already have a guideline as to what
you're going to build so you don't get
stuck with what should I build here or
start building things that in the end
you don't really like and you have to
start all over it's really kind of like
making an outline just if you want to
make a painting or a drawing of some
sorts and the reason I don't usually
feature it is because it's not the most
interesting aspect of the time lapses I
might do it a bit more in the future but
in this case to be very honest I am just
in very dire time problems and I really
kind of underestimated how much time I
had left and especially since I started
making that Palace which ended up taking
an entire day
I don't really have enough time to
finish off this Park in a manner which I
would like to do so so this is just
about the last section of the park which
will be properly finished and now about
the way that this is laid out it still
has not really open feeling that the
rest of the Dutch area already has I
wanted to get a row of Hasan's behind
the coaster to kind of really close it
up and make it one large plaza if you
will within the Dutch area and have that
sort of backdrop and yeah sort of as a
background to the coaster as well if you
look from the main section of the
part of the park now I did end up
removing that little riot since it's
really small and it also calls the
pirate ship to sort of go slightly out
of bounds because I will make the park
map a little bit smaller I'm trying to
get a sort of square footprints in with
this park so it really doesn't look like
it would be laid out as a very small
park with a lack of space would which
are very often just in a square layout
which is pretty much filled to the brim
with all sorts of things and for the
longest time here and that was really a
painfully long time I was fighting with
the path system it's not necessarily
because I couldn't really find a way out
of this but because I wanted to get a
really specific sort of round shape to
this a lot of this path layouts in this
part of the park is already in many
circles like there's a large circular
path around the helix of the coaster
right there
and many of the transitions also kind of
flow that way and I think it just looks
nicest so I wanted to do it again and I
found this sort of trick to get it to
actually do that so where you can see me
doing on the left there is actually get
a very large area of part without
something in the middle
by having a path go into the other
direction I'm waiting to see if I'm
gonna do it again but it doesn't look
like it but I'm not something which I
wanted to use for a quite a while there
you can do it by holding Z because it
just gives more smooth paths that sort
of flow into each other and aren't as
much separate paths that just well
connect to each other because if it's a
theme park you really want to have as
much of a open and Plaza like path
layouts as you want which is one of the
reasons why I haven't been a fan of this
games path system for a long time it's a
bus system that really works very well
and it's really intuitive as well but
the problem is just that it's not very
theme park issues to be many theme parks
have just paths flowing everywhere where
it's more like everything is path except
for the places that are planters rides
and buildings and with the pass system
like this you
almost always just get small paths that
go everywhere instead of these large
winding plazas that you want to have but
anyway that's a bit of a topic that I've
probably talks about a bit too much
already going into the first houses
which is the more pretty much the rest
of this video I wanted to finish this
entire facade and give every house their
only unique touch gable which makes this
the first appearance of the very famous
Dutch gable architecture and yeah I sort
of wanted to make this quite round so it
shows off every Gable as much as I could
and just have all of those unique sort
of facades to get a real touch
atmosphere into this part of the park
and the first one is just a really
simple one although it still took a bit
of trial and error to get it where I
want it it doesn't really have any
decorative thing like stairs or a clock
type of gable it's just a roof with a
slanted front with a couple of windows
and a bit of extra decorations and that
is just about it the inspiration for
many of these buildings is just all over
the place you can find many of these
types of buildings throughout the
Netherlands and they all have nearly
exactly the same kind of Assad which did
make my job here well quite easy
actually since you can just find many
references of what these facades look
like and you just see them copied over
on many buildings in the Netherlands so
these are just the archetypes of
building Gables of you ones and the
basic color scheme for these buildings
is quite simple as well just having the
old bricks as the wall texture and in
nearly every house were actually every
house using these concrete's smaller
pieces to make all of the details of the
trims and pillars on the buildings and
again using some of the wood to make
those streams come out a bit more and
this building was exceptionally handy
actually because when I was building it
at first it seemed like a really
awkwardly empty building especially with
that front not having anything but it
turned out to be the perfect place to
actually place the sign of the ride
itself
which I think fits into the Dutch area
quite nicely I was originally going to
place it in a Scandinavian area if that
was going to come but since it didn't
come as ship kind of bits the Dutch
areas well with their colonial history
and everything like that so I'm getting
that ship sign in there for the ride
since it is the right entrance and
moving on to their next building which
is the all-white building you don't see
them as much but you definitely see them
in many city centers these very large
white buildings which choose to have
classical details and maybe just a few
sprinkles of more touch elements but all
things considered it is quite a
classical looking building and it
doesn't really have that was very
typical Dutch Gables or anything like
that the only thing that it really has
in common as goes with all of these
buildings is that they are on like sort
of the same range of heights they aren't
all that the exact same height since you
never really see that in the Netherlands
but to sort of get an idea of an
ensemble of these buildings they are
sort of in the same height glass tone
not one of these buildings is really
small and there's also not a building
that's much larger than the rest they
also to fall into the same height and
they all sort of have this same width as
well this building is going to be a
little bit wider since it has those
pillars on the side but they're all just
two tiles wide and as you can see what
does make this building look a bit more
Dutch is having all of these whites
cross frame windows it is quite an open
building with a lot of glass and I did
want to cover that up in the front a
little bit by adding an awning and have
tried to make one for there but that
doesn't really work out there's nothing
to really make an awning out of at least
not texture-wise
so I just went with the boring chief
beef awnings which doesn't really fit
the building too much and they're much
smaller than I was hoping for so I might
come back to that at some point but I
don't think there's any way to make any
kind of convincing awnings so it's
probably not gonna happen at any time
and just quickly finishing what would be
well yeah not really sure just the
cornice of the building just the top
part which comes out of little bits on
top of which I can build the pad
the triangular classic also the front of
the building for quite a while I was
thinking that I could also go with a
round top which you do see on many
buildings with very nice details and
ornaments on them but there was no way
that I could figure out how to make that
so I just went with a very simple option
here just get a triangular top and try
and fit all of these different details
in there to at least get a bit of area
sculptures that you see on these kinds
of buildings but uh instead of having
some sort of interesting scene I just
ended up sinking parrots and pirates
into the front since that was just about
everything that I could do here so that
finishes off the building with just a
bit of foliage to make it look a bit
more inviting than the large white area
than it was and have a quick move as for
many of these roofs I had them pretty
made pretty much from all of the other
buildings that I've already made which
is why there are separate buildings I
didn't want to make the roofs all over
again so it just put the already
existing roofs on top of these buildings
here and this building has a cable which
is copied from the gable of the
restaurant just to save time and I
suppose because I'm lazy but um it's a
little bit different
I definitely when it gets very different
details and everything a stepped cable
is something which you do find quite a
lot and since I already had this made it
just seemed like a perfect place to just
copy it and make a completely new
building out of it with a different
style on the side of the building so the
first thing that I try to do here is get
some pillars with these whites layers of
bacon if you will on the sides which
didn't really work out that well me and
they turned out to be a lot more fats
than I was hoping for and they really
came out way too much from the building
so I made some second pillars that kind
of sink into the walls a little bit more
and have a different white texture with
a white texture on the side of them
instead of having all of those
horizontal rings and that should just
finish off the bottom to top plasters on
this building and that makes this quite
a fancy building since this is the
building right in the middle of this
facade or this row of buildings
it is the building which really gets
most of the attention which is like the
most visible from pretty much every
angle that you look at this row of
buildings from so it's the building
where I wanted to put most of the detail
and you'll probably find at the end then
the detail sort of gets less and less
toward the edge and the buildings on the
sides of this row are just the most
simple ones and this is the tallest and
the most detailed one just finishing off
the windows same thing is always white
frames and bit of decoration on top of
it
as well as on the pillars connecting it
to those horizontal things should just
about finish off most of the details of
this building I was thinking about the
door for quite a while though there
weren't really as easy ways to do the
door of this building many of the other
decorations are just keep adding stuff
until it looks good which pretty much
worked for quite a while there but
especially since there aren't too many
doors and I definitely wanted all the
doors to be square I had to sink loads
of different objects into the doors of
these buildings actually get some larger
square doors with white decorations
around them which you don't really see
in the game itself and a few planters
should finish that off quite nicely
because well bit of foliage around the
building always makes it look nicer and
moving on to the second to last building
which is going to be another unique
gable and I haven't been able to find an
english translation for this so if
anybody knows about it please let me
know because I've been looking for it
but couldn't really find anything
basically in touch literally translated
this would be called a neck Gable which
sounds really weird but it's a gable
type where the middle part of the bricks
comes out a lot higher as you can see
and around that you have lot of lighter
detail to accent it so in this case I'm
adding some of these details and round
shapes on the side of it and on top of
it there is that white speak so they're
coming up and that basically finishes
off this gable it looks a bit similar to
the clock gable which is one which I
didn't feature in here because it was
just really hard to make since it has a
lot
shapes that I couldn't really figure out
how to make without extending far beyond
it and not being able to get a proper
roof in so I ended up not going with
that one but eeeh a cable like this
seems a bit more doable in the game
which is why I ended up going for this
the only well small mistake that I made
with this building was that after I make
this door and this window I did figure
that the top of the building is a little
bit too tall it is a two floor building
and one of the smallest of this row of
houses but in the end the second floor
over here is just way too high so I had
to lower that a little bit that aside
though it's pretty much the same and you
can already kind of tell the drill many
of these Dutch houses are very similar
and the one sort of distinguishing
feature in many cases is either just the
texture of the walls or what type of
cable it has because that really makes
most of the difference for these
buildings there are also many Dutch
buildings without a cable which use it
usually they have a hip roof and that's
well the exact reason why I didn't want
to have a house without a cable on this
building because it's really hard to
make a hip roof out of these doors it
might be possible but I was feeling a
bit too lazy to even try that so I ended
up just having these cables on all of
the buildings now the last building and
I was also kind of lazy with this one I
have to say is almost a copy of the
first building it is completely remade
from scratch though but it's also a
little bit taller I still needed toilets
around here
so this is going to be the toilet
building I was originally planning to
have the middle building as a toilet
building but I kept forgetting that I
had to place toilets so this eventually
became the toilet building which is not
too bad it might in hindsight just be
better to have the toilet building on
the side so he don't really
that awkward large opening into the
walls on what is the center of this row
of facades so this building ended up
becoming where the toilets are at and
I'm not really sure what I'm gonna add
to this side of this building my
original plan is to have a windmill
there but whether I'm going to add that
windmill on that bunch of brick roofs
all just depends on whether I have
enough time to do it and if that leaves
me enough time to finish the rest of the
area as well which I'm not really sure
but this should at least finish off the
row of facades quite nicely so if all
else fails and I don't really have
enough time to finish this part of the
park of proper at the very least the
important facades are all done and I can
just start filling in the rest of this
park with some foliage and things like
that and that finishes off the video for
today so thank you guys for watching and
I hope to see you guys next time in
which I'll hopefully finish the park and
see how far we get with that